US Secretary of State John Kerry
traveled to northern Iraq as part of
Washington's efforts to prevent the
country from collapsing he urged Iraqi
Kurds to continue backing the government
in Baghdad in recent days the security
cooperation between the forces here in
the Kurdish area has been really
critical to helping to draw my respect
to ISIL so far Islamists haven't
advanced into the Kurdish region but the
Islamist sweep through northern Iraq has
forced thousands of refugees to flee
into Kurdish territory the Kurds have
had a degree of autonomy for decades and
now there are concerns they could
separate from Iraq potentially taking
with them cure cook and nearby oil
fields that's a nightmare for Baghdad
which is already pressed to contain
Sunni militants guaranteeing oil
supplies is a big issue for the Kurdish
government the isis advance has already
led to fuel shortages and kilometer long
waits at gas stations in the kurdish
city of heavier the region's government
hopes that supplies from abroad will
help ease the problems but currently the
fuel shortage is putting pressure on the
Kurdish economy even as Kurds face war
on their southern border growing anger
at Baghdad was one of the reasons John
Kerry traveled to northern Iraq even
after his meeting with the Kurds it's
unclear whether the region's leaders
still see a future in Iraq